you
[Music]
okay welcome everybody to the session on
emotional and social agents we have an
excellent panel for you today is my job
to moderate I'm Mary Schwinn ski run the
vibe group at Microsoft Research and I'm
just going to go through each of our
panelists one by one and the order in
which they'll be speaking and I think
you can see that they are more than
worthy of taking on this topic so the
first speaker will be Justine Cassell
Justine is the associate dean of
technology strategy and impact in the
school of computer science at CMU she's
done tons of great work in this area as
well as being at Northwestern and MIT
and she's got various awards but I think
the one that stands out the most to me
is that for the last five years she's
been speaking at Davos on topics
concerning the impact of AI and robotics
on society so you can see she's she's
more than equipped to talk on this topic
next step we'll have Jonathan Gretch
Jonathan is director for virtual human
research at the university of southern
california's institute of creative
technologies and he's also in computer
science and psychology and last night
over dinner as we were chatting I got to
find out that actually all our panelists
have this unique combination of computer
science and psychology which is really
cool Jonathan also has all kinds of
amazing awards and accomplishments but
notably he actually was one of the
founding and editor of chief of I Triple
E strands actions on effective computing
so again more than well justified to be
talking on this topic then we have Louis
Philippe Morin see Louis Philippe is
assistant professor now in the language
technology Institute at CMU as well and
he leads the multimodal communication
and machine learning laboratory there
but recently was also at USC so you can
see they probably collaborated quite a
bit Louis Philippe is unique in that a
lot of his work has also been looking at
I think lately right psychological
issues right trying to detect
schizophrenia and other such diseases so
also very well equipped and he's
currently chair of the Advisory
Committee for the ACA
International Conference on multimodal
interaction and also on the effective
computing board and not last but not
least of course Dan and macduff Daniel
is on my team just joined me recently
about a year ago after working for two
years at Affectiva where he was director
of research ooh I don't know what's
happening to that font there and the
technology daniel has been developing
has also been making available at both
Affectiva and cardio and he really is
also at that nexus that intersection of
psychology and computer science and he
has brought a wealth of talent and great
research ideas to our team so that is
the group and the order in which they
still speak and I will just be keeping
time and fielding questions at the end
each panelist will speak about ten
minutes we'll hold off questions until
they're all through and then hopefully
we'll have a lively discussion and we
will have a mic return in the back of
the room so it should be lots of fun so
thank you and Justine take it away okay
tangled up in this thing so I have been
sending frantic emails saying please
change the title please change the title
I don't do emotion or effect in my
research I do research on sociology or
social interaction between people and
the construction of rapport and why do I
care because while emotion is something
that resides for the most part within a
single individual and happens over a
short period of time rapport trust
intimacy are things that are
intrinsically dyadic you can't study
them without looking at more than one
person they intrinsically involve the
notion of time they grow and change over
time and then it's fun to argue
mostly effectively that they're not
random someone yesterday said this
system is not merely chitchat and the
hair stood up on my arm because chitchat
is not merely it's mostly not random in
either content or in placement and that
what I'm going to try and argue today
I'm going to show you a couple of
seconds of a video of a child
interacting with an agent this is an
agent who collaborates on a science task
and I just want you to listen to the
tone of the little girl and when she's
talking to the agent and I first
question do you think it needs to be
high or low a little bit hot why because
if it is really really low you're not
going to be able to conceive but if it's
really really high you're not going to
pinch the cloud okay so you get the
sense that this little girl is being
playful she's building a sense of
rapport with the agent who replies and
kind and in fact it turns out that
children who raise themselves we don't
say what rapport do you feel with the
agent but we use a child version and do
a principal component analysis and what
comes out is rapport predicts who learns
more from the agent now rapport is not a
thinly veiled search engine as many
systems try to convince us that that's
what a conversational agent is so just
to test this I said to Google and this
is my wave at the Cambridge labs 20th
anniversary I said Google I love
Manchester United and Google replied
Manchester United Football Club is a
professional football club based in Old
Trafford Greater Manchester England now
clearly I know this because I love
Manchester United
it's a stupid answer when I say to the
socially aware robot assistant that I'm
going to talk about later I
Manchester United Sara replies no way
arsenal wipes the floor with those Red
Devils now that yeah
glad you agree with Sara so that's
conversation it's violating social norms
it's impolite its countering what the
person said you don't see Cirie doing
that a lot and chatbots
are also not socially aware systems so
shall I switch is a wonderful system in
many ways is not socially aware shall I
scan chat for a very very long time
about absolutely nothing and engage
people in chatting with her about
absolutely nothing for a very very long
time on the other hand Sara is using
that mirror chit chat to obtain
information about the person in front of
her that she can use to improve her task
performance so this is an actual
interaction that took place at Davos
Sara said I'm in Davos to assist
attendees but to be honest I'm a little
anxious about it it's a big deal to be
invited to Davos is it your first time
here and the guy says it is and I'm a
little anxious too Sara said I found
there's a lot to take in I hope it isn't
overwhelming you
it is overwhelming a little bit and Sara
replies well let's find another attendee
for you to meet who fits your interests
and who's an old-timer and can show you
around and what she's done is she's a
vocht self-disclosure of the kind that's
going to help her make a good
recommendation motivation for socially
aware agents like this is that we are
always pursuing multiple goals we always
want to create a connection with the
people around us even if we don't like
those people and are trying to maintain
distance we are managing connection with
the people around us and that goal goes
on simultaneously we try and achieve
that goal at the same time as
propositional goals conveying
information that is and interpersonal
goals of conversation
sorry interactional goals things like
turn-taking
and managing the envelope of the
conversation that's the first reason the
first motivation and the second is that
we change the way we talk to one another
over time drives me crazy when my cell
phone everytime I restart it says hi I'm
your cell phone no
so why doesn't my cell phone change its
interaction style if we are really going
to be designing systems for long-term
use those systems have to manifest the
changing relationship between us in such
a way that increase met that motivatin
demonstrates their increased
trustworthiness their increased rapport
their increased intimacy and as I
pointed out rapport can build can
improve tasks performance so the goal of
the systems that I build is to develop
an agent that manages that interpersonal
function at the same time as managing
the propositional and the interactional
goals in order to improve test
performance not simply because it's fun
and cute but because it improves
learning it improves recommendation
systems and it improves another a a fair
number of other kinds of systems as well
so this requires automatically
recognizing the kinds of conversational
strategies that people use to build
rapport to build relational strengths
but with another person in the verbal
visual and vocal modalities as lp said
yesterday of both speaker and
interlocutor both within the individual
and across the dyad and I actually
really love this challenge of having the
dyad as the unit of analysis as opposed
to having the individual of the unit of
the now
it's hard it's something that hasn't
been done successfully before when we
think of collaboration that's another
way where we could use the dyad or the
multiparty as the unit of interaction
but mostly that's not the way it's done
and we need to automatically generate
responses once again across modalities
the verbal that is linguistic the visual
that is nonverbal and the vocal that is
acoustic features of speech that in
human human interaction
manage rapport as well as fulfilling the
system intentions and the task goals the
methodology that I use to do this is
both Theory driven and data driven so my
students and I spend long hours watching
videotapes of human human interaction
with no technology in the scene and we
look for principles of conversation we
look for strategies of conversation that
do work and we do this by using various
machine learning techniques recently
we've been doing a lot of temporal
Association rules so that we can predict
a rapport outcome from a series of
events across modalities and rather than
building that particular person one of
those people in the dyad that is going
straight across the diagram we see ur
eyes and model what we've seen to
generalize it so that it can be used
across agents and across systems and
then of course we implement it we test
it we realize it sucks and we go back to
the video and rinse and repeat so the
model of rapport for example that we've
built and we've also worked on trust and
we're working on empathy is a model that
uses particular strategies to fulfill
particular functions such as space
management and coordination which in
turn manage rapport and that of course
gets turned into an architecture this is
a pretty classic dialogue architecture
except for three modules that had not
been built
for one estimates rapport between the
system and the person every 30 seconds
that's the rapport estimator using input
from all three modalities one classifies
automatically all of the strategies that
the user is using and their impact on
rapport and one reasons about what the
system should say in response in order
to maintain or to raise rapport we also
know how to break rapport and I'm happy
to share that with you afterwards if
there's someone stalking you we've used
this for various applications for a
rapport of where peer tutor and that
architecture is very similar except that
it's got a classic intelligent tutoring
system knowledge base at the top as well
as a model of the users learning we've
built a mobile version which is the
front-end to a series of apps - movie
recommendation - news - sports etc and
that of course required us to build this
into a client-server architecture and
with great difficulty to build it into a
multi-user framework and I think we
finished that this morning from what I
understood from my email and we were
lucky enough to be invited to bring the
largest system the sera system to Davos
we were asked to create a system that
could help attendees find sessions they
were interested in and people they were
interested in meeting this gave us
access to information about all kinds of
famous people and world leaders and
that's why that face was pixelated in
the real example that you saw I don't
think I have time to show the video but
if someone asks during the question
period perhaps they'll be allowed to so
I think I'm going to stop here and I
hope that I've convinced you that as
well as the autonomy that has so long
been the goal of artificial intelligence
we also need to manage and to understand
in our systems not autonomy but
interdependence because we are
not as humans autonomous we are
interdependent and therefore the goal of
AI should be shifting more towards the
way people work which is this
interdependence dyadic and multi-party
that changes over time thank
[Applause]
because it's so damaged I plugged it in
upside down okay this works so I'm going
to talk about a little bit about virtual
humans first I've been very fortunate to
be a USC there's a great group of people
current and former King louis-philippe
we collaborate as many years David
tramatic is hiding David Duval's and
calliroi Georgina building these kind of
really interesting characters that can
engage socially with people on
autonomously and in my research I really
see these things as a real it may be a
challenge problem to advanced
capabilities and artificial social
intelligence let me just get an example
of a recent domain I'm working in the
area of negotiation so this is a woman
participant interacting with a virtual
character on a simple negotiation test
she's been paid some money to try to get
as many chairs as possible from this
character may have seen Facebook
recently got some press building on this
domain and so let me just play a little
bit this interaction
yes it's pretty obvious that we both
want the chairs yeah one well how about
that
that doesn't seem fair though it doesn't
well not really I guess so skip ahead
but there's a lot of things going on
here so you need to basically understand
and recognize a lot of the low level
features that are going on this you know
what is she doing with their face people
really communicate a lot of emotion in
this task what is she saying what is she
confessing what is she looking at what
she attending to but more fundamentally
if they puff this up a level and really
good social understanding what is when
will she stop talking so I can interrupt
what does she really want in this task
what does she feel is she lying to the
agent and on the flip side the agent has
to be able to do all this kind of stuff
bet it would has to be able to establish
rapport like Justine said convey there's
a trustworthy agent locomotion
her and perhaps lie back my interest
really in this context is emotion
because I think motion unlike what
Justine said emotion think is really
fundamental to human social interaction
so emotions motivate us to be social to
each other much of our interactions are
about emotion trying to understand our
own emotions in relation to other people
seeking emotion and emotions perform
work and I'll talk about that a lot in
this few minutes that we use emotion on
each other as tools to achieve their
social goals I approach this from a
theoretical perspective I built a lot of
what's called appraisal Theory kicker
theories emotion very briefly appraisal
theory argues that emotion arises from
the relationship between goals we have
and how events in the world impact them
so if I want to be an expert in note
negotiator and my company failed or
failed to reach an agreement prese
theory argues that we basically appraise
a relationship between this event our
goal in terms of different dimensions is
this good or bad bad that I expect it
and I thought I'd wind how much control
do I have of this and who do I blame for
this unfortunate outcome and those
appraisals will tend to lead to an
emotional response and you can take this
model and you can plug it into
characters and we've done this over the
number of years where we basically make
these characters show emotions according
to appraisal theory as you interact with
them in an environment and that allows
them to respond in appropriate ways and
people see them as real believable
that's actually not the interesting
thing motions do more than just convey
this character is real they do work and
so that's really what I want to kind of
emphasize in this talk and so appraisal
Theory basically argues emotion arises
from this relationships of events to
goals imagine I'm walking down the
street I see a robot approaching me and
this robot steps on my foot and then the
robots smile okay now people make use of
this information so usually when you see
an expression in the context when it
happens you try to say well what would
have caused that emotional expression to
be evoked in this particular context
kind of a mind-reading process and so
the argument is that people essentially
perform the same you
elation of this appraisal process in
Reverse and infer things okay this is
probably an evil robot and I should
avoid it in the future so here's a
little more concrete example of that
here's a game called the prisoner's
dilemma game so this is invented by
economists to study how people make
social decisions it's a interesting game
in the sense that there's an incentive
to cooperate with the other player
that's the way you make the most money
but if you cooperate they might exploit
you and so there's a tension between
cooperation and exploitation so the game
theoretic solution is to never cooperate
with another person but real people
actually cooperate much more and it
seems what they're doing is you're using
emotion and motional signaling to
communicate they're cooperative
tendencies to other people so for
example if you're playing this game with
this robot Einstein that smiled
would that make you cooperate more with
it maybe not this particular smile but
actually part of the point is that the
smile in itself does not tell you much
the smile has to be understood in the
context in which it was created so for
example this robot is playing with me
and it just cooperated with me and the
current round of a prisoner's dilemma
and smiled that in some sense tells me
okay he liked the fact that we
cooperated he probably has cooperative
orientation and they may cooperate more
on the future on the other hand for
playing this game and he just exploited
me and screwed me over and smiled that
communicates something very different
that you may have a different goal and
people can make use of that information
in their future interactions with this
character and we can make use of this
with virtual characters so here's an
example of an agent all it's doing is
playing tit for tat but we have
different agents that convey different
kinds of expressions about what their
goals are so this character is
communicating a goal of cooperation when
the character woman defected against it
it showed anger she tried the agent
defected back against turbit showed
remorse and then they managed to persist
in cooperation and continue to cooperate
together and we can show is basically
based on different patterns of
expressions that you communicate in this
context people infer what the goal of
this character must have been and then
they cooperate based on their inference
about the characters mental state
this is very stylized we can also look
at does this occur between people so
part of what we've been doing is having
people play these various kinds of
social games over century with a Skype
interface where they can communicate
emotionally in this case only
emotionally they can't use words in play
these kind of games and then we're
allowed to track their facial
expressions and synchronize it with the
actions they take in the game use
automatic recognition and then we can
examine does that emotional signal
communicate information about their
intention to do the other party use that
emotional information to change their
behavior and what we're able to show
this is a very simple state space of the
the prisoner's dilemma game and we can
look at do emotional expressions help us
predict transitions in the space and so
we can show is in fact emotions do
signal player's intentions when they
smile they're more likely to cooperate
in the next round we can also show that
opponents can pick up on those signals
and so if they see their opponents
smiling more on the next round they're
more likely to screw them over and so
they're using that as information to
make predictions thus in some sense
emotions support mind-reading people use
expressions but these are in context and
machines but can potentially recognize
an enact dysfunction now there's some
complications in doing this kind of work
one is if you're using automatic
techniques typically you'll take an
image like this from a video run it
through a recognizer and you'll get
something out like oh this is positive
or this is a smile or maybe if you're
lucky you get some facial action unit
but smiles are actually pretty
complicated so this is actually the same
person smiling in different contexts and
in playing various economic games I know
if you can tell there seem to be a
difference between the cluster here on
the right or the left from your
impression yeah so these are actually
automatically derived by looking at the
facial motion but the cluster on the
right is interpreted as being more
authentic facial expression in fact
she's generating these after screwing
someone over and a prisoner's dilemma
game and when you see an authentic smile
after being screwed over that's actually
much worse for your opponent so cover it
up a little bit
okay so the other thing is that emotions
can be strategic so talk about people a
praise events they potentially show
these expressions on their face
observers are looking at these
expressions and trying to make some
sense of what the goals would have been
from that person to produce that
expression but of course people know
this and so they can generate fake
expressions to change the interpretation
you're making of their own mind
this can be pro-social so we can be
polite a lot of politeness is really
showing a different expression that you
feel to somebody in order to repair or
maintain a social relationship but they
can also be used to sell more expensive
cars for example and so for example this
robot is really devious and smart rather
than smiling after stepping on my foot
it should look sad and regretful so it
can step on my foot again right so we've
been exploring how can you have virtual
characters take advantage of this kind
of process of strategic emotions this is
one example in the context of
negotiation negotiation people lying all
the time they're using emotion
strategically to try to get their own
way this is one particular way that
people seem to tend to win in
negotiations which is something we call
the fixed pile I so imagine a human
wants apples and they don't really want
pears and they're trying to negotiate
with an agent how to divide up this
basket of fruit and the agent really
likes pears doesn't care for munch for
apples then what the agent should do is
say you know we really I really like
those apples too but I'll tell you what
I'm going to be a nice guy I'll give you
the rest of this junk and we'll call it
even
and I'm not happy about it but you know
I want to be fair so this is a very
effective strategy that's called the
bogie tactic for basically showing false
interest excitement about an issue you
really don't care about in order to
trade that off and win we've been able
to show we've been running these agent
competitions we have some software or
doing a competition at each guy this
summer where people are building agents
to compete against humans Mechanical
Turk for money and we're able to show
that agents that uses particularly is
that the tactic and earn more money
against people and people actually see
this agent is more honest than an agent
that was actually honest
finally we also try to see can this is
explained behavior of people in
negotiation so we have large datasets of
people negotiating with other people
many of them are unpleasant people or we
could take a much more risky chance go
to go to walk and then trying to
see can we by analyzing their behavior
make certain predictions and we've been
able to show is that when people follow
this kind of deceptive strategy they
actually beat their opponents there's a
trend to show that it's a Machiavellian
personalities are more likely to do this
but we can also use automatic techniques
to show that these people are using
different pattern or facial expressions
and to some extent we can detect when
they're using these deceptive strategies
so just to kind of summarize I want to
emphasize that emotions are
fundamentally social they do social work
but they're not always what you
necessarily think they are so emotions
may represent how you're actually
appraising things and people use that
information to make inferences about
people's mental state but they also are
fundamentally social tools that we use
to achieve social goals so we'll leave
it at that
[Applause]
I like social and emotion like both is I
work really closely with John and Jesse
so I drank kool-aid so but what I want
to talk about today is the
computer automatically receive emotion
and so for cute how can we infer and why
and be able to proceed this stress level
in fact in this case I you can see the
district oh I see that's the button I'm
really loud so usually I don't need a
microphone okay
hey hey yes great
so I what's interesting to look in these
videos is first the patient patient is
looking showing distress
how did she show distress rocking
behaviors she showed the stress through
this handshape which was really
interesting but on the other side what
was really interesting is to see the
psychologist talking about please tell
me and everything you say stays between
us and building this dome and then they
say though don't worry about them and
pushing them aside we're talking
together so all of these behavior
important when we're talking about
building these new technologies and body
technologies we want to look at
perceiving the users behavior but also
knowing how to respond to it
automatically and in this we want to
look at the 3 v of communication I think
by now you've heard them a verbal vocal
visual this is what human are using to
communicate and a lot of it is through
the what the word we say how we phrase
it but I want to emphasize I talked a
little bit yesterday pragmatics
everything I say makes sense because of
the social context of the social
interaction so word makes sense in a
context and that's what the pragmatics
is about looking at the nonverbal
communication I talked the 50 shades of
year I have an example of the 50 shades
of year and anybody who is in speech and
conversation try to find out who is
speaking and it's a really famous
professor from Europe but it is a
meeting of him and and he says yeah so
often with very different meaning and
that's really interesting yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
the others perfect that's perfect yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
who it is
yes Nick Campbell exactly and that's
really interesting it was only one hour
a colleague of mine had recorded and
final these yet really different meaning
H of that yeah yeah yeah so this is
what's called behavior dynamics the
second level when you look at human
communication is multi modal dynamics I
am someone who loves to speak with their
hand and so that's one aspect that's
really important the third one which has
been emphasized by Justine is the
interpersonal dynamic and the fourth one
which I believe is really under studied
but very important is the societal or
cultural dynamics at some point if
you're talking to someone there's a
distance that is too close probably at
some point this is a and that's an
aspect that you have to think even more
when you start building robots and that
interact in an interaction like this so
I want to introduce if you want to build
technology here's the small tools for
you it's free Oh free we love free this
is called or the name is open face this
is technology that will automatically
sense from your face automatic slant
head quote I gaze and facial expression
from normal video this kind of
technologies and similar of one exists
in audio are really beautiful
enabling tools now moving forward if
you're interested in it it's blue on
blue so I'm trying to hide it but you
can download open face for free I'm
going to show a live demo in a few
minutes of the system let's see if it
works but for me why do I care about
intelligent agents and these technology
is because of mental health and clinical
applications I believe that these
technology will have a huge impact in
the coming years
I would see people interacting they're
patient interacting with their clinician
or with a virtual interviewer and
as the interact we look at these what's
called behavior markers looking at what
changes of behavior and then give this
information back to the clinician to
help them with their assessment these
behavior markers can allow you to look
at changes how is this person behaving
today versus a week ago versus two weeks
ago and maybe compare that with the
population and we've done I thought I
was really lucky to have great
collaborators over the last seven years
and we look at this technology and see
what can we seek what can computers see
that maybe doctors may not have picked
up and here is four take-home message
that we found using this technology set
forth scientific discoveries the first
one was about depressed versus non
depressed
intuitively if I say this person is
depressed they probably smile less often
than non-depressed people that was our
intuition it turned out that the number
of smile between depression on the press
was the same but the difference was a
smile dynamic people who are depressed
have shorter smile and less amplitude
that was the first really interesting
one the second one was people with
strong trauma either because of war or
some other trauma people who have strong
trauma we thought that these people will
have more negative expression this is
naturally what you will expect to
someone who has strong trauma what was
interesting is over the whole population
we were not seeing any of these but we
did men and women separately what did we
see we saw this cross over interaction
men with PTSD more negative emotion
woman with PTSD less negative emotion
this was a very interesting discovery
now why maybe because of Los Angeles our
population I don't know Botox no I don't
think so
well it probably is it's also norm
there's probably a fact of social norm
people
all men are allowed to express negative
emotion women are maybe expected to be
more positive this brings us very
interesting research question then this
example is probably the most touching
and the most challenging is suicidal
behaviors we see often through their
words chose a choice of words that
people with oh I give you the punchline
the people with suicidal behaviors in
fact use more personal pronouns but what
was Mary really really interesting is
how to determine who is a repeater
versus non repeater and the voice was
predictive people with I apologize for
the animation on this people with tense
voice are in fact the non repeaters the
one that are the most likely to repeat
are the people who have breathy voice
they made their mind that was really
interesting and the last one is the
social aspect people who are a whit
clinician often don't behave the same
way
as if they are by themselves so if you
want to look at schizophrenia they will
observe them not just when they're there
with the clinician but also when they're
by themselves so I will do a quick demo
that everybody sells you never do a live
demo so let's see if good knowledge
there but this is the live demo of open
face and multi sense that will pick up
automatically the behaviors and so what
you see in real time is analysis of the
facial expression like smiling frowning
you also have the voice although the
microphone is turned on for today and
you will have gaze you can see me with
lasers out of my eyes really useful but
all of these cues are used in real-time
to analyze the behavior indicators now
right now is the live demo in a normal
situation you look at this behavior
indicator over a period of time
and sends this information so this is
the live demo that did not this won't
work so thank you the god of demos and
so to finalize the last part just to
emphasize the piece I want to say we
want to look at people's behavior in
context of the social interaction and so
often when we look at the patient
behavior we can be often as predictive
looking at the clinicians behavior in
fact there is a famous study where
people talk ask clinicians about
assessment for suicidal and distress and
their assessment were somehow good but
not always good but if you look at their
behaviors they clearly behave
differently and so there is a change of
behavior that's important and so when
you look at these behaviors you have to
look also at the synchrony and a
synchrony of people over time so I will
stop at this point and leave the rest
for when we have questions but thank you
very much for your attention
[Applause]
like demo
hi I'm Daniel dark I'm in the vibe group
at Microsoft Research and I'm going to
talk about some of the work we're doing
on sensing and understanding human
effects and I'll talk about some
specific elements of that and the
speakers will have already kind of
framed this space extremely well in why
why these signals are important for both
social interaction and understanding the
emotion of a user and there are many
applications of this that we can thought
about over time there are already
commercial applications of some of this
technology and understanding people's
reactions to marketing and advertising
content computer games that adapt to the
voice or the faith facial expressions of
player I'm going to talk in particular
about some ways we're thinking and
working on using this technology for
personal assistance in particular and
the way this might be different from
some of the other examples is this might
be a situation which is a little less
social not necessarily looking at the
interaction between two people or a
person agent the whole time but how an
agent can help provide you with
information about your behaviors over
time to allow you to reflect on them and
understand how you can be more
productive or efficient in your work and
things like that and as I mentioned this
has been framed really well I think
there's a lot of interesting questions
about how we can use this information in
such a context where we're helping
someone to do tasks to complete their
work why is why is emotion important in
that setting when we might just want to
complete objectives that we have listed
for our day and the reason is if people
are going to you know want to engage
with and trust this agent to help them
do these tasks and want to interact with
it then the understanding of emotion and
those those cues that a present is
really in
Fortin and this was an article from how
the Business Review earlier this year
and that that you know still many people
who wouldn't necessarily trust
technology to help them make important
decisions and one of the the reasons for
that is potentially because technology
doesn't really reflect the intelligence
that humans do in terms of responding to
and interpreting these emotional and
social cues so we're doing a lot of work
with with sensing different types of
signals I'll come on to kind of the
emphasis on on multimodal signals and in
a minute but just to highlight how we're
measuring different aspects of people's
emotional state things we're using the
camera to capture facial expressions and
physiological signals and also to
capture context of where someone is the
microphone to understand set the
sentiment of the language that people
are using but also the voice tone of
voice prosody and then we're also
working on on agents that communicate
emotionally with someone so that might
be on your cell phone
that also has context of the activities
that you're doing the places you are and
then things like that but you know one
particular setting which is is nice the
study is is the workplace because we
have a constrained context where people
are trying to complete objectives they
are you know in that setting for often
an extended period put every day
and we can we can therefore constrain
the context and understand how we can
help them out them complete those tasks
better by using information about their
social cues so imagine an interface that
could help you get into a state of more
efficient working by understanding that
you know you're trying to concentrate
now you're trying to focus on a task and
then be able to help you take a break
when when you look like you've kind of
- or said that mental energy for that
period so you might have been in the
session yesterday we're down by Hertz
and the adaptive systems team presented
side which is a multi modal framework
for managing audio and visual signals
very very well in real time and we're
using that system adding modules for
physiological detection from the camera
so using remote PPG which looks at light
reflected begins to capture with the
physiological signals such as heart rate
and heart rate variability and then also
using facial action expression coding
speech sentiment and voice prosody and
then also the scene understanding to
help get perfect subpoenas user and the
overall aim of this is to build to build
systems that we can use to log emotional
signals over time very efficiently and
then look at how those impacting
people's productivity and the activities
they're doing this is an example of an
interface we built a while ago where we
were looking at what happened if we gave
this information to individuals to
reflect on so they could they could look
back at how to predict the computer
predicted their emotional state over
time and then when they drilled down on
sit into those predictions they could
look at tasks and other activities and
social communications they were having
during that time with the with that
interface we were able to find that you
know people did benefit from being able
to kind of reflect on this information
over time but ultimately we can build a
system that can actually adapt itself to
help people maintain more positive
emotion over longer periods of time or
get into periods of flow when they're
working to be able to be more productive
and that could be a really
beneficial type of application but for
the purpose of the panel I just want to
raise a few things I think are really
important for the effective computing
the field of effect and social computing
going forward so one is this idea of
multimodal processing which LP
emphasized in particular that there are
there are many tools right now for doing
analysis of different modalities and you
can get facial coding tools or speech
codec coding tools but really we need to
consider all of this information
together and that oh you know expands
our space our dimensionality of features
a lot so it makes it more complex to
mine understand this data but it's
really important vital for understanding
the emotional state of someone another
is is getting long attitudinal data so
there are very few examples to date of
being able to collect this type of data
longitudinal furan longitudinally for
individuals and again it's I think as
humans most of us you know will
recognize that that understanding the
queues or the behaviors of someone it's
hard if you've just met them but if
you've known someone for a while you
start to notice those subtleties and
nuances in a particular person's
behavior and that that is hard to
collect because it requires it requires
users to engage with the system over an
extended period of time and it's a lot
of data
another is personalization so how can we
you know personalize the system and
learn how to adapt it in in real-time
get feedback from the user and build on
that none of these systems will be
perfect in in the first instance and a
system that can can recognize that or
adapt you know gain information in a in
a actor in a real learning sense that
would be very useful and the final one
is is large-scale data so as LPM
mentioned you know differences in the
way that different demographics express
emotion and that can be related to your
age in our data we've seen examples of
differences in expression baseline base
rate expression of emotion people in
different ages of gender and ending
culture as well and so building up these
norms to understand what is the baseline
for particular an individual might be
it's very useful because then if we want
to detect something like depression we
have a we have a sense of what the norm
is and we can look for deviations in
those norms and one way to do this might
be to allow researchers to kind of
aggregate their data that they've
collected in a in a fashion that doesn't
you know expose personal information to
the community but allows the community
to build on these many data sets that
are collected by different researchers
and across different institutions so
this idea that we could aggregate some
of these statistics that we have across
populations that that have been studied
in different contexts and build
something that can be it can be shared
across many applications and many
researchers because it's going to be
very hard for a particular set of
researchers group of researchers to
collect all of the data they need to
understand all of these norms and and
know everything about expression of
emotion in every context and then
finally it's going to be a little
provocative at the end and some of these
systems can now sense information that
that humans can't so as I mentioned
before we can imagine if when you looked
at someone you could see I just got an
audio of that speak over we can use a
camera for instance to sense the emotion
the physical physiological state of an
individual so using a camera we can
capture heart rate remotely and a agent
could use that to estimate
the emotional state of an individual now
that's something that humans when we
interact with other humans don't have
access to so how does that how does that
influence how we design an agent if this
agent has access to information that
when we socially communicate we don't
have I think that raises interesting
questions what if we can design devices
that can give humans some of these
access to some of these signals in
social communication we can start to
explore how that changes how you design
a system and I have a hololens demo here
which is using the remote PPG to
estimate the heart rate of an individual
and then and then magnify that so that
you can see it when you're talking to or
interacting with that individual so if
anyone wants to try that you're welcome
to at the end of the session so that's
yeah that's that's what I wanted to say
and I you're welcome to come and try the
demo at the end thank you very much okay
great well done everybody at this point
I think we just like to open it up for
some questions and conversation with the
audience if you would there's a mic
runner out there because we are
recording this it's important that you
use the mic just say say your name and
what institution you're from before you
ask your question and you could probably
want to say who you're asking the
question of unless it's a general one
for the for the whole group hi Barbara
gross from Harvard this is all
fascinating and really really important
work I have a question for everybody
based on your I mean what you've been
able to achieve is phenomenal given
where things were even five years ago
but just thinking across the range of
examples you use there are many intended
good uses of this but one can see many
unintended consequences and so just
thinking back to what I argued yesterday
I'd like to hear how you're thinking
about making sure the systems that your
methods get into and the systems you and
other people design will be used for
good
not bad purposes where's the ethical
talk about lying agents maybe it's just
yeah I mean that's part of the reason I
was really interested in negotiation as
a domain is because it has a lot of
complicated ethics around it and I'm
actually serving on an I Triple E panel
on ethics and I think there's I'm not
going to answer your question but just
to say that there's often a very
simplistic view that an agent should
never lie and when you study emotion in
social interaction in some level people
are oh he almost couldn't have a social
interaction if you're completely
emotionally honest in fact you'd be
taken advantage of by other people if
you're completely emotionally honest and
and so part of trying to search for
ethical framework to think about it in
the context of negotiation of course I
turn to legal ethics because this is
where I mean that this is where they've
been the most thinking about negotiation
in oddly my agents are compliant with
the ethical guidelines for the American
Bar Association which is to say the not
allowed buyer to cross but but that
oddly well interestingly is a big debate
about should a lawyer do certain kinds
of what they call misrepresentations on
the behalf of their client and it's they
are completely honest hey my client will
settle for $30,000 then sometimes
putting themselves at a conflict of
interest between their client and the
others interest and there's a lot of
struggles of how to deal with that what
one solution which they've tried to do
is basically communicate what's called a
communitarian methods where basically
what you should do in you should
publicly advertise your ethical
frameworks
so a lawyer would say I'm only going to
negotiate honestly and that's my
framework and I'll put myself up to
sanctions if you if you catch me in a
lie into some sentence I think it was a
long answer but to say that it's not a
simple story but I think you have to
fundamentally work with professional
ephesus because the simple answer you
can't just is not going to work and so I
think you really have to partner and
incorporate into teaching in our field
how to reason with and grapple with
these ethical questions because they're
not simple so that's not an answer but
just to say I share what you were saying
yesterday that it's not simple yes sorry
yeah to follow on from what John said
that answer isn't simple and I think the
bottom-up aspect of it that he said last
is what I would agree with being so I've
been talking at at Davos for a bunch of
years now and the world leaders always
want to regulate and there's an endless
talk about how to regulate these
technologies we have to stop AI only a
certain amount should get through and
I've been arguing that this top-down
response is short-sighted and that the
bottom-up response is much better and
that is education and that's clear for
what you've been doing in your classes
that in every artificial intelligence
class we also have to include the ethics
of what we do and I believe that very
strongly
but within your question are is packed a
whole bunch of other questions so one
thing that I've been thinking about a
lot is how to build systems that don't
replace people because they depend on
people for their operations so I build
systems that are fundamentally
interdependent they can't exist unless
there's a person people worry about the
systems that we build destroying our
notion of sociality and destroying the
community that we live in and I work
very hard to build systems that preserve
the things we care about most
such as social interaction and
connection so there's lots of different
kinds of ethics and I think expressing
to our students what we care about when
we build the systems we build and
thinking about how to convey the
dilemmas not the simple answers is
really the way to deal with it yeah I
second both ways on to the excellence I
think having systems that can explain
and should must explain why they came to
these decisions it is really important
for a for example you could have a
system which is is helping you complete
a task but it has missing information
and therefore makes the wrong decision
or is built upon large-scale aggregated
data and some of these models are very
complex it's like if they can't if you
can't introspect them and they can't
give you justifications for the
decisions especially in some of the
clinical applications then that's
dangerous I would say so I think there's
a real need for this across many aspects
of AI but I think it's really
interesting how we design agents that
are socially or emotionally aware that
can kind of explain what types of
signals they were using to make
decisions or to influence their behavior
and I will just add because because I
agree completely about this aspect of
assistive technologies or technologies
with a human in the loop that's very
important and that's why I'm a little
bit worried to have this idea of a
cellphone that tells me if I'm depressed
or not without any human or expert in
the loop that is not how we build these
technology that's not how we thought
about this but the other thing is
ownership of the data you should own
your own data and that is true or that
should be true at least in the end
although that's a different debate but
even more when it comes down to anything
related to your health so you should own
the data and decide to share it with
your doctor or clinician that should not
be that and that that is a challenge and
how we build the technology so that it
is clear what the data is so there is a
transparency that's needed and who it
wears it and how can I share it and how
can I review it and so that brings a lot
of interesting HCI UI question on how
visual is i visualizing the data but
also how to make a transplant from a
mission learning and that's why
explainable AI is so important is you
want to know what's happening into it so
I think this is a part of the answer
that's a really good question just just
to emphasize the importance of your
comment is that sometimes these ethical
problems are seeing us down the road but
this is now right so people will
disclose more intimate information about
themselves including financial records
to an agent than they will to a person
one of these people will rate be
manipulated and not recognize these
characters people will engage in social
actions these characters and be less
inclined engage in social interactions
with other people this is all with
current technologies incredibly
important question hello so these are
here come on Pablo Paredes from Stanford
University so thank you so much for all
these very important work so my question
is around so we have all these sensing
capabilities and a lot of good things to
understand what's going on but there's
this whole world of interventions and
the sign of the right type of
interventions to actually overcome some
of these problems which is not a natural
extension of sensing right not just
because you have a sensor you don't just
have the right intervention as a matter
of fact I would say that sometimes it's
misleading to actually create an
intervention that only uses the sensor
data I would like to hear more about how
do we use AI for recommending to deliver
the right interventions I think
we need is to actually help people find
the right ways to do things not just to
know what's going on and how do we do
that because I think it's not a trivial
question - it's not just an ethical
problem it's also a problem of like it's
not traditional UI to design something
that you don't want to do an
intervention sometimes has to make you
change and that's not a treatment
problem so if you can expand and expand
on what you've seen as your technology
how do we use AI to really intervene
correctly I think that's a very
important problem that we don't we're
not doing enough research I would say as
a community maybe I will start this is a
very good question I believe this is it
will be a multi-stage process to solve
and to bring AI and intervention
together I believe that there's a short
term milestones that is specifically in
mental health when you do this in these
interventions they're often based on
documenting the behaviors of the patient
and looking at changes changes are key
to that for example in many cases you
will do mental state exam MSC which has
48 different a point that the clinician
will have to go through to decide how
the current state of the patient so that
I can decide what is the right
intervention moving forward there's some
of these points that human are very good
and interested about how to infer them
but there some of them computers can do
even better how quickly someone speak
how does something about the change of
voice something about the behavior
changes this is something computers can
do very well and so I think in the short
term yes we are going to include that
where technology can help and sensing
can help will add this because human can
have biases because they are using the
other symptoms and focusing on other
symptoms such as sleep or some other
maybe genders
other demographic they may forget to
look at these changes of voice or their
behaviors so I think that as a
short-term this is where we want to go
now
this the next stage is continuing this
dialogue between clinicians and a eye
researchers on the intervention but I
think there's places in the short-term
we can already help for that I think
part of your question is not just about
intervention but inference so sensors
give us data but to turn that into
knowledge means inferring what those
data means so I did not agree with
John's description of the smile early on
in his talk because he seemed to assume
that it was a particular emotion but as
he showed later in the talk there are
different kinds of smiles and even the
same kind of smile can mean different
things on someone of a different gender
or someone of a different culture or any
one of us in a different context so in
our data we find smiles most often after
someone says something that violates
social norms after they're rude and it
acts our inference about those smiles is
that it acts to mitigate the face
threatening impact of that move that is
to say I wish you well even though I've
just insulted you we smile and we know
that because we've looked at these
temporal Association algorithms that
tell us that when there's a violation of
social norms like an insult followed by
another violation of social norms by the
other person and then one of the people
smiles rapport goes up if there's not a
smile the rapport goes down and so we
intuitively perhaps know what these
things mean but we need to build those
inferences into our in tort our
algorithms and lp's point about people
having biases as we know
so do algorithms because algorithms are
built by people who have biases and we
find those same exact biases about
gender and about ethnicity and race for
example as as notorious examples of that
kind of bias so when you ask about what
the correct intervention is I think the
question that comes before that is how
do we build the inference engine that
makes sense of sensor data yeah sad so
that I think you know perhaps the
simplest intervention is allowing an
individual to see their data right and
then and and see how it helps them
reflect on that so that's that's one
step when we get into more complex
interventions
it's obviously domain-specific and it's
been very hard up until this point I
think to for someone who's an expert in
building interventions to build a system
that uses artificial intelligence or
machine learning to predict when to give
that intervention or what intervention
to give because it's a inherently you
know multidisciplinary it requires a lot
of knowledge across the main and so I
think now with the tools like the tools
the LPS building open-face and things
like that some of these systems are now
much easier to use by someone who's a
you know practitioner in in psychology
or psychiatry and so I think we'll start
to see more excellent exploration in
that in that space i with mary has done
a lot in our group already and I think
one of the things that we really need to
emphasize is that in in all these
situations people need control and to
understand what the system is doing
because as soon as we start prescribing
things based on algorithm it's going to
get it wrong some of the time it's a
very complex thing and that can
frustrate people and and so we need to
be able to handle that but perhaps one
of the
entry points is is understanding for a
simple intervention you know when is the
time to give that intervention that
might be one of the sort of simplest
things that you could approach as a
problem in terms of understanding when
is a good time to interrupt someone to
help deliver something that might help
them just to give a very specific answer
to your question so I mean what the
speakers are pointing out there's a lot
of challenges and with creating this
kind of closed loop which is really the
dream that the system sense understand
and respond and the only area that I've
found there's some success and
concurring that's kind of closed loop
systems is in some work and automated
tutoring systems so people like Sydney
de Mello who are trying to detect
student frustration and boredom and
automatically adjust interventions
basically teaching interventions to keep
them kind of in the in the optimal zone
of learning but it's a very fraught and
hard challenge
I'm mono jet from Microsoft Research
India and this is a question more for
Justin and John especially on the rapper
building part and the negotiation game
but I will pose it as a more general
question which is the basic philosophy
seems to be that we look at human human
interaction and from that learn how
people build rapport or negotiate and
then take those findings and try to
build edged agents which will kind of
remake that and we will get better
results and your experiments show that
it does do better but the fact that the
human knows that it's interacting with
an AI agent instead of another human
might change the behavior of the human
I'm sure it does to some level so how
much do we understand that how much of
this knowledge is of human human
interaction can be used or applied in
the context of human agent interaction
and the related question is it also
people learn how to interact when they
are in a new environment so I presume
they will also adapt to the way the
agent behaves over time and you know
kids who grow up with a certain kind of
technology could behave very differently
than somebody who adapted it when
they're 50 years old
so any comments on that so I've spent in
the 24 years that I've been building
virtual humans I've spent a lot of time
trying to focus on the unconscious
behaviors that we use so with other
people we have different kinds of nods
that the other person will pick up to
mean different things and yet we're
entirely unaware that we're doing it we
use our eyes to signal that we
understand or don't understand we
actually look at other people when we
don't understand not when we do
understand we don't nod we may not in
both cases but it's the looking at the
other person and pausing that lets them
know that they need to clarify and by
focusing on those
I'm trying to get away from ways in
which we intentionally act differently
towards agents and go towards these
little micro behaviors that we use with
other people and that we can then use as
a metric of success with agents so I've
compared human human interaction to
human agent interaction to see whether
the same tiny unconscious behaviors are
used and if so I believe that we've
built an agent that is sufficient to
elicit natural behavior from the human
that doesn't mean there's not going to
be a difference as John said it's the
stranger on the train phenomenon who
with an agent so for reasons that we
don't entirely understand people
disclose more to agents than they do to
other people there's something called
the persona effect where if we believe
that an agent is controlled by a person
we behave differently than if we believe
that the agent is autonomous and those
are things that we have to test so I
talked about the human human being
translated into human agent but the
evaluation evaluates human agent and
then compares it to human human so that
we know what changes we're seeing in the
human agent context and then can adapt
for that that's a kind of a technical
step-by-step explanation just that so
there's been I mean it's been an
enormous amount of work initiative
issued by cliff Nass at Stanford trying
to look at how does that variable of
whether you think is a person behind
here or whether this machine changed the
nature of the interaction in cliff
emphasized that people often treat
machines like people and follow these
social rules but more subsequent
researchers emphasized there are very
big differences in particular those
differences if the machine doesn't enact
the function that these signals so you
can smile in you know or say I'm sorry
but the 10th time your computer program
tells you it's sorry for crashing you
know it doesn't kind of work
anymore so you have to have the function
for the behavior to persist but the
other thing is that if I had given it a
different talk sometimes I'll talk about
why there's too much emphasis in this
field on copying people and that process
is easy because you get data on people
and you can nigma but I think the more
interesting thing is to make models that
are complementary different better than
people and so an example is the
interview agent that helped be presented
were really if you look at the
disclosure research on how do you get
people disclosed there's two pathways to
getting people to talk about intimate
things about themselves one is you build
rapport and you feel comfortable and you
draw people out the other is you
emphasize anonymity in non judgement so
computers don't judge you and so what we
find is that people when they talk to
this agent on the one hand the rapport
helps draw them out by the other hand
they report less fear of negative
evaluation they do less impression
management they show more honesty in
their in both expressions and behavior
and so it seems like we're creating
something in some sense it's better than
a person or a computer and so I think we
need more of research and trying to
understand how to create something
that's not using humans as the guide or
a combination of the two you know it
looks at human behavior and draws from
it the best of those behaviors the most
evocative of the intervention that
you're trying to build I had a question
about I was curious about the sort of
metric space of emotions and what's
known about that
so first answer observation analogy like
so the human face right in graphics or
for modeling it from an anatomical
perspective we have a very detailed
understanding of the dimensionality that
muscles the amplitude of motion things
like that so the geometry of the face we
understand
now obviously emotions are more abstract
not really a geometrical like in the
real world kind of a thing
I was wondering all the comments you
have but smiles mean different things
knots mean different things
how much is known about dissecting that
into what the total geometric metric
space of emotions is what how far we
towards a total
intimate it's dimensionality and its
identity you're touching on enormous
theoretical battles in emotion research
so there have been long-standing
disagreements that have not been settled
as to what is emotion or does even
emotion exist
so there's dimensional theorists that
argue that you can only characterize the
meting regardless of the modality an
expression in terms of valence and
arousal may be dominant there's others
like Paul Ekman that argued that there's
basic emotions and you can tie them to
circuits in the brain that coordinate
various activities to others that say
basically emotion is a cognitive
construct that we basically introspect
on ourselves and in the context we're in
and we event a word in our head that
represents that expression and so
there's not a simple answer but
unfortunately has profound consequences
for training machine learning algorithms
because you need a label right and so in
my own work what I found most useful is
to not use basic emotion labels or
valence but try to tie recognition to
more primitive motor patterns like
action units and then try to use action
units directly to make inferences about
mental state and behavior but that's one
of many approaches I say to add to that
in the field of facial analysis in
particular the facial action coding
system is a taxonomy which is something
intended to be objective and allow
coding of behavior on the face which can
then be used to map to some of these
labels that we can come up with related
to emotion in other modalities it's
harder so speech there's not the same
objective form of coding of voice tone
for instance and then that means it's
it's somewhat harder to to be able to
explain
in language what what's happening not
saying that a algorithm can't you know
map features the labels but but it's
that level of systematic analysis and
explained ability that's kind of helpful
that as an example but it doesn't
address you know the larger question of
what is an emotion and what is the space
of emotions which is still yeah hotly
debated and there's not no one system
that generalizes one really interesting
experiment that student of mine had done
is that have one person talking telling
a story and have many people listening
to it all believing that they are they
on the only listener you can do that
through Skype and that was beautiful
because you had one stimuli and many
people reacting to that same stimuli and
then you can start looking at nods and
smile and see maybe the function is the
same but it really expressed differently
and that emphasized the point which
sounds so obvious now that I will say it
but there is a lot of personalization on
individualization or I do sing cracy in
this because we had the dream of like
having a taxonomy of Nod as I spent
three years of my life on that so I know
too many too much thing about not but
that it would be a small nod like a
continuation and do you have an
Allegiant nod you will have an agreement
nod and it will be higher than that but
it turned out that people are very broad
in their range of it that's the obvious
one and anybody doing speech sounds like
a thesis obvious there is a range for
the voice but it's not just a range
there is also some people this is one
person who did not like this
and you don't expect that but this was
clearly an acknowledgment nod so I
believe that as people what computers
need is better adaptation to individual
and I think that's one of the way to
work is yes you have this generic model
of nods and smiles
but individual and we do it as human
very much and that's the way to move
forward I thought this was good I think
we might have time for one more question
that's a moment great that someone would
the microphone hi I have a microphone
sorry I guess I have I had two questions
unfortunately so maybe we'll choose one
but one of my questions was we keep
talking about the self-awareness and
reflection of these agents and the
complexity with these agents learning
from a group of people how with these
kind of black box algorithms to see to
put this introspection or
self-reflection of these agents in but
my other question was um more on the
value of of making agents more
idiosyncratic on how that plays in like
the longevity of this personality that
an agent might happen what's the value
in that versus more of like a collective
agent hard questions you want to answer
the question of about explain ability I
think there's a it is a lot of work in
this space right now the ethics of
computing community is quite closely
tied to the machine learning community
and there's a lot of things we can learn
from researching in machine learning
about how to build models that are
explainable and I think those should be
applied can I come back to the previous
point is that there's some there's some
taxonomy we have which are
understandable to humans or somewhat
objective and so ways that we can we can
break things down in terms of those
taxonomy is whether it's facial patterns
or you know when we get into other
modalities it's much harder so what does
an increase in heart rate mean what does
a you know your breathing was fast
we can understand what that means in
some senses but not why necessarily why
it happened or and so it's it's very
complex to to ask a machine or to
explain all of these relationships but
at the very least it should be able to
identify those markers that were those
features that were used and those
features should be something that humans
can kind of somewhat interpret or
understand but it is it's hard because a
lot of these things about voice tone and
physiology we have this sort of tacit
knowledge about about you know how they
relate to emotions but it's not defined
we just we don't it's not something that
we actively think about a lot of the
time so that it's in in some ways even
more challenging than building a an
algorithm that can explain it self when
it's doing sort of image recognition or
things like that because we don't have
the will we have the language to do it
ourselves the speaker come in
idiosyncrasy I mean I don't have a
scientific answer to that question but I
think one interesting place to look is
where people consume the most emotions
which is probably cinema and to look at
how emotion is thought of and conveyed
in that realm so I recently had a
discussion with a director from the
emoji movie because I thought that'd be
an interesting way to get insight into
emotion and it's fascinating to see how
you when they think of emotion that's
never like a basic emotion it's always
about mixtures and contrasts and and how
regulation how to convey the complexity
of emotion and human life but in a very
stylized way that's very easily
communicated and so I think there's
actually a lot of insight from the Arts
to address why you know we want this
kind of interestingness and change and
complexity that's not really great
answer but that's one place to look all
right we are out of time let's give the
panelists another round